so I buy the Nintendo switch we had a
lot of questions in from readers I will
get to those a promise there's a bunch
between GameSpot and Twitter and whatnot
but uh lucky enough we have Pete here
who is at the reveal then well I mean
not the reveal event but the North
American event in New York if it hands
on the hands on event right so we have a
lot of questions for you people have
questions for you in terms of actually
getting to play it and try things out
I'm just kind of want to go over basics
first breath of wild release March 3rd
there's no bundles yet they say they
want to keep the price down it's gonna
be like three hundred dollars $2.99 what
would that become the UK they said like
for the UK prices or sorry for Europe
prices check like local retailers or
something I don't know what so who knows
but yeah it will be $2.99 in the US over
here $300 launch lineup breath of the
wild one two switch once you switch
super Bomberman are let's go let's go
through so breath a while I think people
know it as the nudes Legend of Zelda
will be Wii U and Nintendo switch when
you play that game you meet characters
along the way and then the characters
change a little bit oh right I forgot
about that change you learn more game
has everything yeah it'll be it sounds
like a an epic writes okay that one to
switch which is a game that utilizes the
joy cons which are the little like
handheld remote things that attach to
the tablet and he uses them in a lot of
different ways that would be the one
people know for the milking thing the
milking the duel yes for those who don't
know and so we're not just talking about
milking without context can you explain
that so let me so the the joy Kahn's
these controllers they have motion that
can detect motion and they have little
cameras that can detect like gestures in
front of it so some of the minigames
make use of the various features the
milking one it detects you know you're
moving up and down and pressing buttons
trying to milk a cow and you're
competing at someone else who's milking
another imagined imaginary cow and it
sounds so weird but one of the things
about this game is that when you're
doing it you're basically faced forward
looking at somebody else now I don't
even know how you people deal with your
close friends but I can't stand it like
stare at Mike for more than a couple
seconds before I feel awkward
maybe that's just you but yeah lucky for
you we sit across from each other and
it's great but imagine at a party right
you and in total stranger are going to
be mill
imaginary cows well like deadlocked in a
stair it's it's super weird I don't I
don't want to do that and you'd be
surprised though it's it's it's a new
feeling like it's definitely different
than anything else I've experienced
playing a video game yeah I was
surprised this wasn't a bundle thing
because it's sort of like a minigame
compilation kind of style game like
party game and you think in line with
what sports sports or I mean much lesser
extent obviously I was really surprised
they didn't it's like $50 I think yeah
I'm also surprised yeah I mean there's a
bunch of minigames it's not just milking
right like there's one where you have to
guess how many things are inside a
little box by moving it and like using
the vibration that's when we have to
like eat in front of the controller by
chewing as fast as possible there's like
ping-pong you can play like the list
kind of goes on there's a lot there but
yes it's the showcase of Technology
which you think would be the great a
great thing for Nintendo to have with
every switch because it no matter where
someone is if they see switch they will
play one to switch like the Nintendo
land or the Wii she said yeah but the
regi of court you know talked to him and
he was like well you know by not
including this game we're giving people
the chance to choose the games they want
and we're not raising the price of the
system he equated it more to we play
which was that and follow up to Wii
Sports that came out with Wii but that
also came at a time when there was new
hardware that we emotion plus I don't
really get I don't really die with his
comparison but it's certainly a
fascinating game you guys think of other
games I know it's about like real
splatoon fan Kelly yeah my biggest
problem with splatoon was the lack of
voice chat which I understand but for a
game work there's actual you can get a
strategy together you can be a heavier
you can be kind of like the equivalent
of a scout in tf2 or like there's
different loadouts you can do in
splatoon and there's actually layers to
it not having that like I would just be
on skype with people that I knew when it
really limited the experience and so
force which I know they have like that
mobile app for voice chat I don't know
what the capability would be so that
would be the biggest thing I would be
looking for in splatoon too um but I
really enjoy splatoon it's it's fun it's
different did you immediately know it
was a sequel when they showed it at the
review Lord because I mean there were
rumors about a port right so I thought
that's what this was
than with new weapons and characters but
I know it's a complete sequel I didn't
play my splatoon so I would be the last
person to know but a few people in the
office were like oh this is an entire
sequel I was not expecting I straight-up
thought it would be a port because I
feel like we a lot of us expected that
after kind of thinking oh Mario Kart 8
is gonna be a port which turned out to
be sort of true they get it it's a
deluxe edition instead but I thought
this was gonna be a port I was like nope
well tune there's so many opportunities
and this is coming I think September so
it's not quite a launch title yeah to go
back to what you were saying about using
a smartphone app to do voice chat
basically the message is if you don't
have a smartphone your switch experience
is going to be lesser yeah like
multiplayer will probably not be a thing
for you
Reggie basically said well if you don't
have a smartphone the switch isn't free
whoo and I'd talk to him which is kind
of crazy his reasoning was everywhere I
go kids as young as 5 have smartphones
so who doesn't have a smartphone so who
are we really leaving out a lot of
people it feels like some of the like
some of the ones who switch games that
are you know like trying to prove the or
being like a proof of concept for the
tech art geared toward like the family
crowd and maybe the the younger crowd
and I don't see how that lines up with
there you know you need a smartphone for
this yeah I mean like I know like I have
nieces and nephews who are 10 and under
they all have access to smart devices
but they're not really like theirs right
so I think for kids is a good means for
parents to sort of regain control over
what their kids are doing like you can
set limits from your phone like okay the
system won't work after this time like
you can do something like that but it's
very curious to see them you know it's
Nintendo right so we expect they're
gonna present hoops that people have to
jump through to do things that other
platforms have figured out a long time
ago I'm just surprised it's this that
it's telling you to another piece of
hardware yeah I mean I guess I can see
like Nintendo expanding into the mobile
market with Mario Brown even the the
success of Pokemon go sort of indicates
that the the I guess the equivalent of
an install base is there for yeah
smartphone users and Nintendo but it's
still really bizarre like a
three-year-old you will use their
parents phone I guess yeah no no it's
weird to me from a business perspective
get it because your point it's sort of
like solidifying in tendo's relationship
with mobile devices yeah
so even away from switch you look at
your phone and still that subconscious
idea of Nintendo in your hands yeah and
so you'll go to their other games but
for the average person it just seems
like it's gonna be a pain in the ass
what is the overall deal with online
capabilities of the switch because when
they first explained it during the
reveal is kind of cloudy haven't really
explained anything and they say it'll be
a separate thing that will launch a
month after or something with if I'm not
no I remember it well I don't know about
the delay to launch but you will get
there will be a free trial period for a
certain time like six months or
something like that and then people have
to start paying no idea about what it's
gonna cost or what you get with that
yeah I think the subscriptions start
like paid subscription starts and fall
you will be getting one free Nintendo or
Super Nintendo game every month with the
service okay but I thought it expires it
expires like a yearly thing what do you
mean by it expires after the month oh
the game does that's shitty it's not yes
plus you own in your library I mean it's
shitty only if you consider the fact
that Playstations and Microsoft have
sort of established these new norms yeah
but on the other hand if you think about
it just from a if you want to be
positive about it which is I think
healthy in some cases right like an
uncharacteristic this is the thing that
will bring people together around a
specific Nintendo franchise at the right
time to make them feel like there's a
strong community maybe before the launch
of a charities all the game or whatever
so it does suck they're taking it away
but they are actually introducing things
for Super Nintendo games like online
multiplayer which has never been a thing
of a virtual console before sure so
that's pretty exciting yes it sucks you
lose these games but Virtual Console
games are cheap right five to ten bucks
what kind of gamers would have
multiplayer for Super Nintendo like
Zombies Ate My Neighbors Sony Mario Kart
and starfox Street Fighter right that's
hopefully like the library games they
released is good like month I'm well
hopefully I mean I think the biggest
question right now is where Virtual
Console stuff from Wii and 3ds even
transfer over yeah that's the
frustrating thing for me because I've
bought many of these games and multiple
times in my life and so it's that's why
it's frustrating that you don't get to
keep it that it expires but obviously
I'm I'm sure we're more of a unique case
than me
they're kind of thinking of people who
maybe you try you know yeah Super
Metroid for the first time right and
then you kind of get into the series
that way and that's why it expires I
don't know I understand the thinking
there
it's just I've paid $10 multiple times
for the same games when I grew up
there's a service called Sega channel
through my cable provider where I could
literally subscribe to Genesis games on
a monthly basis so I would get like 12
games a month that I could just play at
the end of the month they'd change to
new games I didn't mind it it was
actually like a nice little natural way
of giving me some yes it was there were
limitations involved but at the same
time it was it forced me to try new
things so that that was what I was
worried I have a lot of like Virtual
Console games and and I know like
transferring between 3d asses when I got
my XL that was a pain and getting like
all those like Zelda games I had from my
regular 3ds to the XL I'm hoping they
can figure out how to streamline all of
that they have the my Nintendo account
stuff like set in stone and that only
came out about a year ago I want to say
mmhmm so it stands to reason that
they've figured this out they understand
the criticisms so I would be shocked if
your purchases don't carry over we say
that yeah it would be a really bad PR
movement end oh absolutely
so and I also wanted to just kind of get
your impressions with hands on because
we saw a lot about the joy con and we
saw that you can put ice cubes in it and
shake it around did you did you
yummy am assuming you watch the reveal
that night before you went to the
hands-on what was the point of showing
that so the rumble feature in the
controllers which they call HD Rumble
this is different than what you'd
imagine from a typical game controller
so the game I was describing earlier and
similar to the ice cubes scenario I had
a little wooden virtual wooden box with
balls inside of it and I had to tilt it
various ways and like guess how many
balls are in the box so while tilting it
I could feel the balls like rolling down
the controller right and like hitting a
certain spot so you actually get a more
tactile sensation that that recreates
some virtual thing in the palm of your
hand so the reason for showing that on
the the stream was to really communicate
there's something different here but
it's really not so you get a hand on it
that you actually understand like oh
yeah this does feel different so see any
like applications for that in the future
games outside of just this that
proof-of-concept mmm I don't know sure
they would I'm sure like maybe it'll be
in breath of the wild somehow I mean
we're gonna see it incorporated a lot of
stuff yeah I mean it's one of their it's
one of the key differentiators of the
switch it's one of many but I think
Nintendo is for better or worse focused
on highlighting the things that they're
doing differently right I mean for the
worse they made the gamepad a
requirement for every Wii U game pretty
much this time it seems like it's softer
more smaller features they're gonna
highlight so I think they're gonna
continue that trend but it just won't be
as obtrusive in general from your hands
on time can you tell us what you thought
about this just I don't know general
terms the switch how'd it feel
between the joy con and actually like
playing it mobile and also when it's
docked and you playing on a show you
sure so playing breath of the wild on a
TV using the pro controller pro
controller is incredibly comfortable I
like it more than any other controller
out there right now which is a shock to
me on any platform yeah yeah and you
know the gameplay on the TV I they put
me really close to it so it's not a fair
comparison necessarily like playing on a
couch the game had a lot of jaggies it
didn't look that better than that much
better than a Wii U game that's said I'm
not surprised right I mean this device
is pretty thin it's not purported to be
twice as powerful as Wii U it's just
purported to be a portable game console
so in that sense it's like okay breadth
of the while is pretty much what we saw
back at e3 on switch the difference
being now that you can take it and play
it on the go with the you know the joy
cons in the tablet playing with the joy
cons attached felt a little strange more
comfortable than the gamepad but still
not quite natural but if you use the
kickstand in the back of the tablet and
prop it on a table and disconnect the
joy cons and just hold one in each hand
that felt surprisingly good so if I'm in
a scenario where I can put the tablet
down somewhere and actually detach those
I will do that before I will hold it in
my hand okay
but when you go and you play a you know
a multiplayer game and you use the joi
cons as individual controllers they feel
a little strange
yeah for one they are not the same set
up the joystick and the buttons are in
different locations to accommodate when
you do have it attached to the tablet so
in a two-player scenario it's a bit
unconventional in that sense like you
have to reach over to use the analog
stick kind of far right when they're
attached to the analog on the
is gonna be well it's oriented
vertically rather than horizontally so
vertical is the priority when it goes no
horizontal fashion that's when it sort
of shows like yeah this is this will
work but it's not ideal but that said
you know pretty pretty pretty happy with
the hardware overall it feels
unlike the Wii U and even the Wii it
doesn't feel like a toy necessarily it
feels like a really nice piece of
hardware throughout the various products
that are involved ok but in general was
it easy to figure out everything between
docking and going mobile it's all pretty
streamlined in terms of figure now
completely intuitive ok yeah I mean
every game just reacted as I would hope
when I disconnected or connected
something what did you get to play aside
from like breath of the wild and the one
to switch stuff where those go me too no
I played Street Fighter which is not
that exciting arms talk about arms yeah
really curious about that actually yeah
so this is a game that you don't have to
use a motion controls with but that was
the only way I could play it so that's
the only way I can really speak to it
and so that you sort of if you do you
guys know virtual on virtual on the old
Sega series no so it was a twin stick
game where you had like two like flight
sticks let's say and you had to use them
to like move robots kind of like tanks
in a way so this kind of mimics those
same controls so with you know joint cut
in each hand you tilt both hands in one
direction to move your character that
way and then through various button
presses and motions you direct them to
jump punch Perry or unleash like a super
attack it's it doesn't seem like it's an
intuitive game but give it just 10
minutes and you actually pick it up
pretty easily mastering it is not so
simple but being able to be an effective
boxer that comes pretty quick I do like
the idea of kind of delayed attacks
because of the length of the right match
so you have to actually lead someone or
you know like actually think a step
ahead rather than just like a fighting
game which is very reactionary correct
not that you all good fighting game
players will be stinky a step ahead but
arms especially because the distance
between the two fighters looks kind of
interesting yeah I mean there is
definitely like you get into that moment
where you're like yeah we're like time
slows down and you have to kind of think
about like okay what are my options what
are they gonna do when you screw up and
you get punished
feels bad but when you succeed because
you thought of a strategy and enacted it
effectively feels pretty great yeah and
that it was weird arms will be releasing
when Jews I think we assumed as a launch
title when they showed it to us right
it's not no I'm pretty sure it's June
yeah so launch title and generally once
you switch Zelda mm-hmm super Bomberman
did you play that at all no didn't get
chance to I'm a huge like Bomberman 64
days yeah
prepare to pay $60 for bono are you guys
did you per your pre-order a switch
Kelly eye cream planning on I couldn't
get it I was I was really busy writing
stories but you want during yeah I want
to I want to get it but I just I
couldn't get a pre-order and I really
want this all the master Edition I
couldn't get that either yeah that's one
way that actually comes with the Master
Sword fifth bad in general I think the
joke right now is that the switch is
like a Zelda machine at launch it's like
you're paying 350 to pick to play Zelda
yeah but you know what like I said
before it looks exactly like the Wii U
version so if you're on the fence and
you're like oh I've got to play Zelda
don't worry if you've got a Wii U just
honestly you could play it there and be
happy I think it's playing wind waker HD
on the wii u last night i was saying you
know what game looks the same as this
like in terms of visuals like breath of
the wild kind of doesn't look all that
much better I mean it looks gorgeous
it's a gorgeous art style and whatnot
but ya know it's a great aesthetic it's
vibrant it's clean you know it's very
cartoony and charming but it's not like
a technically demanding no
representation I mean you say yeah I
mean you're a huge anime fan Kelly you
said the trailer that we saw for breath
of a while the longer one was very
animated super anime I was really
surprised it was like a Ghibli I get
that a lot for Ghibli or Ghibli I don't
know I say Ghibli I say quickly but yeah
it was really good G DVD huge oh yeah
you're right it's not it's Ghibli No
well as a kid I said Ghibli but you're
right anyway that's not really what
we're talking about but yeah it was it
was really especially like Zelda crying
was like the most anime crying I've ever
seen
from from just weeping but like I said I
mean like yeah yeah yeah so I don't know
that made me more excited I was
say I probably will play it on my wii
you just so my wii u gets some use and
so i can justify the the money I put
into it but I really want the mass
tradition I might be that person who
buys the mass tradition and then just
plays it on Wii U but I want that
Metroid so like that's to give you a
picture of how in deep I am with this
game already did you get the chance to
play it at e3 last year I did ok it was
like art I think I played it twice I
went back there was a lot of people like
GameSpot before you got here like
favorite game at e3 just like that was
we came back to the war room at e3 and
it was pretty open demo so we all came
back and already after just an hour each
with the game or 40 minutes or something
whatever it was we were all talking
about these crazy things we did that we
had no idea you could do like these
emergent situations everybody did a
different things so I went back with
Miranda Sanchez who who's at IGN and she
did a different thing and we kind of she
picked up where I left off and she like
she went to a mountain that I didn't
even find and like went sailing across a
lake and it was really cool that
everybody found a different thing in
that demo and so I was really excited
like I can't wait to explore that game
on my own time and really see everything
there was to do and try different
recipes and like there's just so many
layers to it yeah and that's really
exciting for me I like the openness of
it but I didn't really get to do it done
like a mini there's like mini dungeons I
like started one and then my time was up
there's like a hundred of my main time
was spent going I like doing the stealth
around the enemy camps bo Cobb linear
modeling camps or whatever they're
called and I'm just like stealing their
weapons before they could get them
because they didn't have their weapons
that's cool I like that a lot and then I
didn't I tried the cooking briefly
didn't really get it I got Hobbit making
potatoes taters boil imagine the sticky
minutes to just side note if you're
gonna download legends all the breath of
the wild digitally this also leads me to
another question that a lot of people
had in terms of a memory and whatnot but
breath of the wild if you download
digitally will take up over 40% of the
consoles base 32 gig internal storage
yeah mom not even taking to account like
how much the OS is up so it's like right
I think it's 32 girl like half already
yeah and so it's 13 on Wii U and 13.4 on
switched yeah
and so that doesn't even count for how
much the OS will take up so you know
you'll have probably even less than 60%
left yep that makes sense
so people a lot of people asked actually
so this probably good time to get to the
reader questions and whatnot obviously I
don't know if you can answer all these
but from your experience and from your
experience covering it and whatnot
they did ask so external hard drives
will be supported right at launch no new
or not no people but micro SDHC cards
will okay and I I might be wrong the
limit is either 2 terabytes or 256
gigabytes I don't know if they I don't
think they have to terrified SD cards
but I could be way off I think I saw
that an article yesterday and it made me
scratch my head but 256 gigabytes is
definitely available so you can you can
buy those and you can you know quadruple
your spacer ok yeah people I said that
was from Bob Jones 198 on a Twitter
though yes he's asking if a switch would
dock switch dock would support external
hard drives and he asked if Pokemon
stars will be a switch game that's this
game's not confirmed I think that was
mainly a joke from him but I figured I'd
ask anyway
did you hear whether there's like a
trophy system in place with a switch
no people suggest that I asked that but
I didn't have enough time I'm talking
about ok because I haven't heard any
news I don't know if you did I haven't
heard anything okay because I Andrew
jelly on Twitter is asking and you can't
really Nintendo style so I I mean if I
had to guess I would say that that
probably wouldn't be in Tendo is just
not with it what are the things that we
you has like badges or something what
are the Nintendo badges I don't know the
Wii U's whether they're changing me
versus gone StreetPass is not a thing
yeah but again these my Nintendo counts
exist and correct me if I'm wrong but
Super Mario run does have like a like a
small achievement like system right does
yeah so if that's any indication yeah
maybe there will be no they don't I know
Nintendo kind of likes to put that on
the back burner he's like it's more
about the experience than showing off
like how much you completed which is
just I mean historically that's their
style so if they did I imagine it would
be kind of more hidden or more minor
sure I don't know and I was Joshua
Harmon on Twitter thank you for the
question about the trophies or
achievements or in
no cloven and then I wanted to ask
someone I just kind of want to touch on
the price itself which we brought up
obviously but saya Khan gamespot was
saying prior to the latest which event
was the first time I've been open to a
new Nintendo console in a while having
owned one since n64 I'm heavily a PC
console player and haven't owned a
mobile system since a gameboy color but
the idea of a device that combines it -
it sounded great to me with Zelda and
Mario to boot
but then that was until the latest
streaming event $300 sounds like too
much to me particularly with no packaged
game that's putting in competition with
ps4 Xbox one both of which heavy was
easily acquired at around 250 dollars
with a bundle game and are much more
powerful and it doesn't compete with the
3d edge which can be found cheaper
ultimately I'd be paying $360 for Zelda
which just isn't a big enough driver so
Sayaka wanted to know what you guys
think of the price and lack of bundle
options I think we talked about the lack
of bundled stuff yeah you know switch
once you switch is a is a no-brainer so
that's done that's not included yeah I
don't buy the comparison to ps4 and Xbox
one because this is a totally different
product this is not a system that's like
a we're a powerful gaming system and
we're gonna have all the third-party
games you love come play them here and
not those other places no this is a look
we're a Nintendo machine we've got some
really weird interesting stuff going on
you can't do anywhere else so naturally
you're paying more for these bits of
hardware that aren't just the tablet
itself so yeah I mean 300 does seem a
little bit high but if you consider the
cost of Nvidia shield tablet which I
think is $200 basically it's the same
tech the switch is a little bit smaller
in terms of dimensions but again
Nintendo's packaged in a lot of extra
stuff I think 250 could have worked 300
doesn't seem too far out of left field
yeah I'd agree I I was I put my money on
250 you know we were kind of getting our
predictions together but I don't think
300 is outrageous
what do you guys think this in terms of
the switch being kind of also obviously
like a living room console but also a
mobile device what will this mean for
like 3ds and 1-9 things like totally
different experience no things to
compete at all no I don't think they
will compete at all the 3ds is compact
enough depending on the model you can
fit in your pocket you will not do that
with switch unless you're stupid because
you'll probably drop that thing or sit
on it it's it's just too big too too
inside of a pocket even then the 3d s is
super portable it's got better battery
life it's got a lot of games built into
it you don't want to play console
experiences the same way you want to
play a 3ds game which has typically
tailored experiences for portable gaming
right so maybe you only have 15 minutes
on the bus right you're not gonna want
to jump into Mario Odyssey for 15
minutes when you can play something
that's built to be fulfilling within
that limited amount of time so you see
the switch more as in terms of being
mobile you see that more as like a
roadtrip device or like playing in a
different room at house it's better yeah
it's a matter of convenience rather than
it's it's it's real identity I think
it's a convertible it's not a portable
mm-hm
yeah like for me that the main draw is
I'm super nearsighted and so my TV is
like slightly too far for certain games
and so having the option to bring it
closer is very different than bringing
my 3ds on Bart and playing Pokemon for
20 minutes on my commute and being done
with it and kind of like being satisfied
versus playing Skyrim and just having it
closer to my face yeah yeah I can't when
I'm using a 3d s I can't I don't really
play like 3s on my commute or anything
like a lot of people do I can't really
get into a game the same way that I
might if I'm at home obviously but I
don't know the switch seemed like when I
heard about the switch I thought oh
that's awesome I can keep playing
something it sounds like what I thought
the Wii U was originally supposed to be
something I could take on the go which
that's was my main concern with a switch
and really I'm probably gonna preorder
it and I love Zelda and I think I just
want to be back on Nintendo's side or at
least I'm always rooting for a Nintendo
but I want to get back like I want to be
involved again and the switch is my
chance to do that especially considering
Zelda's launching with it I try to play
every Zelda like day one but I was
really hoping it would actually be um
actually like a mobile slash kind of
living room experience but of course
that doesn't make sense for them because
the 3ds does really well for Nintendo so
why would they step on their other foot
by doing that right I mean look at the
battery life it's three hours tops
pretty much so I mean yes you can hook
up a battery if you've want like a USB
battery and power this thing on the go
but back to your point about the Wii U
anyway about you know being portable
even just within a home a Wii U gamepad
is not as portable as it should be now
like I can never get a good signal
whenever I try to do that remote play so
now there's just no question
it's like there's no you're not jumping
through any sort of like weird
technological Hoops to do it you just
pick it up play it put it down
attach controllers that's it there's no
caveats yeah and I do want to go back to
what you said about this is what the Wii
U what we all thought it was supposed to
be and I I sort of see them kind of
expanding on that idea and improving
upon it and I do think the portability
throughout the house as part of that
like if you're sharing a TV if you are
in the living room and like somebody
else wants to play a different console
or watch TV or whatever it is having the
ability to move unlimited versus the Wii
U I couldn't even go into it like when I
was in an apartment I couldn't go from
the living room to my bedroom like it
just didn't work and so I think that's
an another factor versus taking it
outside and going to a completely new
location with it
yeah because once I played I don't know
like Wind Waker HD I realized oh they
just this tablet is just supplementing
the experience in cement map and
everything and then if I want to be like
in my kitchen next to living room I can
play it for like a few minutes while I'm
cooking something but yeah I'm not gonna
be able to take this on the bus or
anything but not that I would take a
gamepad on the [ __ ] boss but it's
still we would I guess they would but I
guess my oh speaking of battery power
Josh Shaw former GameSpot was asking can
you charge the cable while playing the
TV or does it need to be docked for the
three hour battery life that's I was
saying earlier you can use battery oh
you dimension as the amperage is correct
you can charge it while playing okay
cool and then I guess my last question
before we close up a segment could I
have a loaded question but the point of
the segment is what do you think the
switch are you optimistic now the switch
is announced or do you think it's I
don't think it's too little too late but
I'm at the opinion like I said it seemed
very much like what I thought they were
going forward the Wii U and it seems
like they're going for the same audience
they were going for with the Wii U if I
was to believe Reggie during his
interview where he said that okay our
biggest failing with the Wii U was the
lack of games so if I'm to believe that
he said we're taking this seriously and
that's something we're addressing with
the switch which you know we will offer
a steady cadence of of Nintendo games
and third-party stuff I think this thing
will be okay
I don't think it's competing with the
other consoles it's competing for money
that might go towards other gaming
experiences but I think anyone who
invests in a switch and likes Nintendo I
have a hunch that this will work out
better than the WiiU it doesn't even
it's felt like for a couple generations
now that Nintendo hasn't even been
trying to compete with the other
consoles in the same way that they might
be just trying to corner their own
demographic and it seems like they're
not even attempting to you know compete
with the power of the other consoles or
the same audience right yeah it's not
their deal they do totally different
things and that's why I mean experiments
sometimes failed so the Wii U is like
okay we're gonna try this thing it
didn't work and so if they go back to
switch and have the gains then I I'm
also optimistic about maybe getting a
better install base then the Wii you had
I do I do think that the not that it's a
mobile system but the option to play
sort of handheld esque is more palatable
to the Nintendo audience I think
Nintendo's success has been on handheld
for some time now and so people who are
already really into Nintendo games are
accustomed to playing them that way and
so having that option is really smart I
think hmm yeah so in general I'm I'm
optimistic I'll be pre-ordering it when
I get the chance I did not yet but don't
know if you still have the chance there
they'll have more in stock before they
release it speaking of would things
intend always does don't they always try
to create the demand upfront they're
only selling 2 million worldwide at
launch all right well I'll get it I'll
find someone who got a couple maybe
there's 2 people in the office that got
to each okay then you'll be ok you have
to do just enough rain on your parade
Brown over here just alright anyway that
is uh it was our long discussion about
the Nintendo HP thanks so much for your
hands-on insight from those joy cons and
those cow udders anyway for those people
watching leave us your thoughts in the
chat if you haven't already or leave
your thoughts in the comment below if
you're watching this on youtube or
GameSpot and let us know what you're
gonna pre-order a switch what you think
about the launch lineup what you think
about Nintendo's future
[Music]